[Musique]
en direct du canada dans un studio qui
est plus grand que la capsule soyouz ou
poissy radio canada international est un
canal arte éditions du vendredi où on a
le plaisir de vous rencontrer et aussi
des fois de rencontrer certains
collègues qu'on a boudé durant la
semaine parce qu'on était trop occupé
alors autour de la table nous avons à
l'image du drapeau du canada mes deux
amis ici on à aller ce chantage tandem
bonjour alice cimpor jours stéphane
marais j'aurais également s'est joint à
l'équipe aujourd'hui bonjour et deux oui
je pensais pas qu'on partait comme ça
sur la lune j'aurais amené ma
combinaison d'astronaute pour ressembler
à david saint-jacques n'a peut-être mais
vous savez lorsqu'il ya une des femmes
qui étaient exposés de sortir lors d'une
mission
la combinaison était trop contre qu'est
ce qu'il s'est passé
elle n'est pas sortie donc après ils se
sont ravisés ils ont amené la bonne
combinaison
bon je te demande une chose que les
taxerait pas parlé avec l'étalon non
plus pas la bonne pointure non pas mal à
personne dans l'espace ne marche comme
ça avec des talons qui marchait pas ne
laisse pas non vous flatter mon plafond
je sais qu'on pourrait faire une
émission sur l'espace c'est pas c'est
pas l'imagination qui restait sûr que
c'est un sujet très passionnant mais
quel est le sujet cette semaine de
discussions voici une autre vidéo 5
images et tout le monde à la maison avec
vous jouent le jeu parce que personne
ici est au courant sauf moi quel est le
sujet aujourd'hui de l'émission voici
cinq petites images et il faudra être
précis parce que ça peut sembler évident
mais non les bateaux way des beaux
bateaux en tout cas de guerre ou de oui
tout à fait un monde où ça si c'est en
europe
quelque part on est un espace qui lui
tout à fait le président voici le mot le
président voici long l'olympe rigide
owen wilson watchmen tout à fait notre
sondage c'est de la fête new ça encore
une fois regardez moi ça n'a jamais par
sa partie à part la réalité c'est un
photomontage est comme la question est
sérieuse qui peut encore faire confiance
à l'amérique de donald trump
parce que aurait nom n'a été prouvée par
des volte face
incessants par des décisions inattendues
et puis le canada qui est un partenaire
économique et politique majeure des
états unis j'ai passé six états unis
voient ça comme ça montre que nous c'est
notre personnel politique de terreur on
se pose des questions d'autant plus
qu'une réunion à l'otan ou encore on va
sentir que trump est pas tout à fait
d'accord avec le peu d'argent investies
par les autres pays l'avenir même de ce
que doit faire cet organisme alors ça
c'est dans les cartes et bien sûr il ya
en arrière tout ça un président qui est
affaibli peu importe le résultat par une
enquête sur ce qui s'est passé en
ukraine
on va parler de ça avec un spécialiste
pour le moment place au jeu avec la
serre aux log qui appuie sur le bouton
et voilà premier tour de la grosse boule
ya trois jeux par émission pour ceux qui
ne savent pas j'appelle ça le moment
d'humiliation on va essayer de les avoir
alors sans vous la perdre et on vint
bull pour le premier jeu après à perdre
des difficultés à dire ça avec sans
émotion aussi première question on
affiche en date du 3 octobre dernier non
9 octobre dernier donald trump avait
fait combien de mensonges et fausses
déclarations
selon le washington post alors moi déjà
je vous dis d aucune de ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses que c'est
beaucoup plus question vous pensez vous
moi j'veux pas mal si vous me racontez
pas des histoires que je ne crois pas
alors elle d'idées pour marine moi
j'irai avec un maximum parce qu'enfin il
est devenu comme une espèce de mental
tronic donc j'irai avec la réponse c est
bien 8435 en tout cas ça se termine par
425 ça s'est su laisser 14000 ben on va
aller je préfère une petite vidéo pour
vous parce que j'aime les graphiques et
j'aime que ce soit bien détaillés mais
on est comme washington post ici où le
new york times andrew on ne recule pas
devant la dépense pour bien être clair
dans nos explications
évidemment les choses se font à temps
des fleury la réponse mais la réponse à
100 aviez vous allez voir qui a raison
qui a raison c aucune de ces réponses
très loin du 14 mai treize mille quatre
cent et cent
5 voilà et sur sweeting tinto poste et
puis j'ai ajouté un petit graphique
parce que moyennement et ça commence à
grimper pas mal au milieu de l'écran
prescrit un point rouge peut apparaître
vous dirai ça c'était aux élections de
mi mandat il a commencé à mentir un peu
plus et apparemment si on va à l'extrême
droite de l'écran
la courbe s'accentue encore davantage en
ce moment avec les histoires de punch
mais aux états unis c'est à dire que
c'est un hyper président et c'est
pourquoi c'est un hyperprésident qui se
garde qui se démarque par son mensonge
perpétuel ou des demi vérités à parce
que pas toujours des mensonges que des
prix pour les 5 10 ou 20 des
demi-vérités donc au regard d'un côté
plutôt que dire tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment en tout cas c'est un geste pas
comment ça se compare à d'autres
présidents la réalité en face qui sort
ce qui n'excuse jeu les experts de
savait jouer qui sort le livre porté les
deux côtés ouais comme ça s'identifie au
fait qu news on dit ah vous faites
défectueuse
je pense que monsieur trump a beaucoup
aidé à la cause d'effets toulouse mais
peut-être que le terrain était propice
ça semble que le jardin était bien
préparé on va en parler avec un
spécialiste de la politique américaine
d'ailleurs gars qui vient de faire
offrir un cours à ses étudiants à vue le
je pense qu'il le fait en ce moment même
politique présidentielle les professeurs
de politique américaine vient c'est vide
de sainte-rose florida il s'agit de
daniel marien monsieur marié mon jour
alors vous vous êtes avant de parler des
grands enjeux des grands des grandes
questions tout ce qui se passe à
washington lui demain parlons de ce qui
se passe dans vos propres glaces
vous êtes un gars qui vous adresser en
principe à des gens qui s'informent des
étudiants qui ont pour devoir de
s'informer le plus possible et vous
faites face à quoi à cette polarisation
et on ne croit même pas des fois des
articles que vous leur donnez surtout
s'ils viennent de sources en général
bien cotés comme le new york times
raconté mois ce qui se passe dans vos
propres classes ouais alors c'est un cas
intéressant mais quelqu'un qui illustre
les états unis la culture politique
américaine ben bernanke puisque
d'épistémologie ya plus de pub la
référence universelle
furibard c'est vrai alors il ya
peut-être trois semaines ou un mois dans
mon cours sur la présidence on ne veut
ni le recul et un article du new york
times qui faisait le survol de la
diplomatie de dollars g à l'égard de la
corée du nord et le deuxième article qui
racontait finalement qui suggérait que
pendant que les négociations piétinent
et que monsieur trump s'imaginent qu'il
fait des progrès avec la pression parce
qu'il fait des aimants s'ils allaient
faire de progrès et bien la corée du
nord multiplie les dj style de l'opic
tirs de missiles a rapporté moyen ou
court portée est réussie elle formulé me
céder à tester des missiles qui vont
dicter d'anvers à faire pas parce que ça
permet à sony cela d'éviter les
compromis si on peut comme artiste pour
les détruire en vol que cette
technologie pourrait effectivement plus
qu'a voulu sévère continentaux vous
pourrez rejoindre les techniques donc un
article avec moult avec beaucoup de deux
de documentation met en évidence que la
diplomatie de monsieur tranquille pu
parce que tes débuts des délais
d'américaines et la dénucléarisation
complète de la correction a très bien vu
par thomas doret qui anima plus qu'à ses
débuts une version c'est ça le but un
métier tram comme des précédents
présidents bush va mal et bien sa
politique
la cause en est juste ou complètement
alors là il ya certains portables me
suis trompé mais c'est en général les
supporteurs de m
ce sac est important de noter c'est que
la plupart détient pas c'est que cet
article était biaisé alors j'étais
estomaqué je ne vous ai faite au mcee et
je lui avais demandé à 1000 biaisé
comment est née la semaine suivante on
est retourné sur ce sujet et après une
discussion il ya des étudiants qui y ont
finalement admis que la cité vraiment
état critique n'est pas fait et autres
qui entend rester avec une déculottée
culte est biaisé ce que ça te montrer
c'est pas mal mais j'ai mal dans la
population des liqueurs il y à un espèce
d'effet de on ne sait plus pourquoi on
pas ce que disent les médias
il y avait la guerre fox news qui
n'était quelque chose
chose qui n'a pas beaucoup dur il
développe un certain suivi de toute
information
alors il ya ses habitudes épistémologie
et ne se transfère une partie à la clé
et voilà c'est une pression est
cependant matin difficile à gérer sur le
plan comité pourrait nous obliger à ça
près bien oui daniel marien moi je
parlais tantôt d'un hyper président qui
dirige une hyper puissance et qui se
démarque par toutes sortes d' extrême en
parlais tantôt de près de 14000 mensonge
en quelques années
dites-moi est-ce que je veux dire cela
pourrait avoir un impact sur la
superpuissance que représentent les
états unis est ce qu'on peut considérer
que sur un plan strictement géopolitique
et même jour stratégique
l'hyperpuissance est en train de perdre
quelque part un peu de sa superbe
ah oui certainement
on parla château nationale s'ils
voulaient toutes les limites et les
tanks des sous marins ne sauve pas le
prestige mais aussi la confiance qu'on
peut vous accorder alors au niveau de la
confiance bien on l'a vu par une série
de politiques eux les diplomates ne
gouvernement ne peut plus vraiment faire
confiance à la limitation 3 on a vu ça
et regarder avec la décision de retirer
les troupes américains du nord de la
syrie récemment qui ont subi ce n'était
rien sacrifier les coupeurs les alliés
turcs qui avaient contribué de façon
importante à combattre les démons il
existe
moi je n'ai pas de l'information
privilégiée est celle et les rites de
match mais je vais jouer dans leur peau
et un je ne ferais pas confiance aux
prises d'entrée ça c'est certain et donc
ça résulte ils voulaient le short parole
des états unis sur l'échiquier mondial
et soeurs était sa commune très bien
rose à l'agenda approche politique obuts
politique de la russie avec platini
routine qui
on construit une aire d'influencé
pourrait aussi venir des marines à rien
est ce que ça veut dire que dans les
médias américains
on devrait faire un peu comme dans vos
cours c'est à dire pas seulement
analyser mais expliquer au tour pourquoi
l'analyse a été faite de celles faste de
façon particulière c'est une bonne
question je pense qu'on fait ça un peu
d'amis médiane unique et une greffe de
savoir si les électeurs ils ont le plus
susceptible d'être confus par cette
relation ne pense pas que les gens
sélectionne les médias veulent le dire
et il est en passe nous est dit pour sa
part des à-peu-près est d'accord sur ce
point m si enel ou encore les médias
sociaux
alors je pense que les gens sélectionne
d'enlever ce qui leur plaît mais
finalement les gens qui renferme dans
des silos qui sont des chambres à eco et
voilà
pas d'entraînement
c'est très ennuyeux je suis pas exigeant
réalité de perception alternative de la
réalité et en plénière misère son
enseignement s'admire en affirmant je
veux gagner notre exemple un cours de
maîtrise le mépris alors on est étudiant
à la maîtrise du jeu une petite équipe
et que les 15 premiers tic ont enfin
annoncé la personne fernand c'est que
les musulmans bien aimé dans un enclos
puni pour nous tuer alors comment voulez
vous voulez vous qu'un petit poster des
trois heures
encore par semaine et déconstruisent des
ventes est que moi c'est un défi est
mort quand il y en a un autre des fils
devant nous c'est de mettre les choses
au clair c'est cette enquête sur les
agissements du président par seulement
dans l'histoire de l'ukraine mais il ya
eu d'autres disent pas précédente qui
nous donne une image de l'homme qui
poussent aux limites mêmes dépasse la
limite souvent sa phase et l'impression
qu'on a vu de l'extérieur peu importe ce
qui va arriver à washington dans cette
enquête sur ou à la conduite du
président dans la sphère de l'ukraine à
l'extérieur cc c'est un homme qui va en
sortir affaibli même s'ils devaient
remporter ces prochaines élections on
passe pas à travers ce genre d' enquête
sans laisser derrière soi beaucoup de
cadavres beaucoup de 9 ans dont il veut
sortir affaibli ni où il va sortir
encore plus déchaînés alors il va sortir
fm simplement dans l'opinion
démocratique
le match est devenu par mois pour avoir
le feu sur marine excuses certains
sénateurs à sa place du caire qui voit
grand pour ne pas tuer d'après ce
sénateur maintenant des états compétitif
où on peut envisager que pour ne pas le
destituer comme dit jean abadie au
niveau du 30 août la réélection de mes
propres
il pourrait donc sinistre pour avoir un
effet négatif sur sa réélection à vie
des délinquants mais c'est vrai mais il
pourrait pour être interpréter le fait
d'un pas le destituer après qu'une
chambre depuis longtemps un protégé de
fitch moody's article de mise en
accusation
ça pouvait le renforcer ça pourrait
décliner monsieur tron et je t'avouerai
un ami à venir du sentiment demande de
revanche que le pare balles
alors si tu te distraire de prédire
quelles seront les conséquences
politiques de ce processus est un
processus conflictuel dynamique
et devenir beaucoup de gens qui vont
vous faire des pétitions moi je suis
sceptique envers à ses prévisions
confirmées ou évaluée par les événements
justement j'allais vous demandez ça va
quoi le bilan de cette polarisation
on l'a vu dans d'autres pays quel sera
le legs de cette polarisation pour les
états unis
je sais pas je ne peux pas répondre à
cette question
un processus qui semble s'approfondir
qui semble n'avoir pas de fin en est
rendu à leforest pu imposer ou les
imaginer imaginez les gens c'est pas
seulement que des gens ont des balades
ce terrain c'était qu'il n'aime pas ceux
qui ont des valeurs différent et on est
en année un point vous voudrez
république et ne veulent pas que leurs
enfants marie 1 1 1 ou le démocrate et
vice et versa démocrates ne veulent pas
que leurs enfants fréquentent ou marie
un ou une république et alors où des
publics alors on en est vraiment dans
une situation d'hostilité civique qui
s'approfondit
il ya des matches qui faisait l'argument
que la polarisation et intérêts des
élites politiques de ceux qui sont venus
de ceux qui sont au gouvernement de tout
des journalistes
il s'intéresse à la politique il est que
la masse des miliciens des tapas
polarité je te plains partisans cette
vision a changé parce que cette
polarisation gagne les matches jusqu'à
un certain point
et voilà juste savoir était juste où se
marient
comment ça va s'arrêter comment
renverser la chose je sais pas je n'ai
aucune idée en tout notre être atteint
dans les deux cas d'accord personne
n'est très content de cette polarisation
enfin peut-être de donald trump oui mais
beaucoup de gens dans les deux cas ne
sont pas contents de polarisation des
politicologues se gratte la terre est de
savoir comment améliorer la situation
c'est pas évident et voilà je sais pas
comment ça va ça va
chantal oui j'allais poser la question
de savoir cette possibilité de destituer
le président des états unis cristallise
toutes les attentions un un peu partout
dans le monde mais on sait qu'il n'ya
pas eu des tonnes de destitution d'un
pitch mène aux états unis il ya eu
quelques cas je veux savoir
n'assiste-t-on pas là une sorte de
théâtralisation du jeu politique juste
pour distraire l'opinion en face d'un
président qui paraît à quelque sorte un
peu bidon
non je suis pas daccord 8 et les
autorisations toujours en particulier
monsieur le droit est un animal de
télévision comme vous le savez il ya eu
très peu de déception en fait le
président johnson qui avait succédé pour
une angine avait fait part sur un
processus qu'il n'a pas été enlevée n'a
pas été destituée finalement par action
yamar une voix une seule voie au créneau
pour destituer elle par la suite le
président experts nixon oui il lui était
pour faire face à une processus de
destitution
il a démissionné avant l insa c'est
parce qu'il s'était rendu compte que les
sénateurs avant son parti n était pas
pour le protéger de la destitution
d'état pour voter la destitution alors
je voulais il a fait deux
il a créé un empire strikes comme on dit
en anglais il a fait le coup afin que
cesse ce produit là il ya eu le premier
temps le kindle ou qui allaitent faire
avec et fait face à des accusations de
deux le thème pitch met à la chambre des
représentants puis au sénat il a été
exonéré par le sénat
et puis maintenant on en est avec le
prix sera mais voilà c'est vrai qu'on ne
débute pas facilement aux états unis en
même temps c'est ironique par se tient
depuis le prise d'embaucher le plan
obama
on parle beaucoup de destituer le
président est dans la maison blanche et
qu'on n'aime pas je me souviens très
bien moi je vais dans un rush très
conservateur et sous la présidence obama
y avait beaucoup de doublons sur les
pare chocs que une pinch and beach
bavard un pays chaud ballon rond
on parle beaucoup dans le public de
destitution depuis le
roche table et mesdames on a un cas où
jésus sur la chambre des représentants a
lancé un processus de destitution
donc on a des attitudes pas facilement
mais peut-être ça va finir comment ça va
se terminer cette chose dont vous êtes
d'accord que enfin c'est pas juste une
manoeuvre dilatoire quelques pas pour
distraire l'opinion par rapport à un
président qui commettent toutes sortes
et de bourdes
non non tu ne suis pas d'accord avec ça
du tout qu'il faut voir un peu ma
décision était d'entrer à la chambre
d'abord la chair et de matelas dans la
chambre d'un pelosi a été l oeuvre d'un
processus de destitution à reculons elle
ne voulait pas sa gauche voulait donner
dans cette posture depuis plusieurs mois
est elle attendue
il y ait des vêtements des révélations
que madame claudie était très inquiète
elle de conserver sa majorité à la
chambre des représentants elle sait
qu'elle est à peu près 45 ans membres de
sa majorité
hilton a décompté où on était compétitif
et ou si on a cette profession qui
paraît arbitraire
elle pourrait perdre cette majorité en
2000 et donc n attendent une fois qu
elle je pense que c'est pour deux je
pense qu'il ya deux considérations d'une
fois considération dont jouit dans sa
décision de lancer une enquête de
destitution ce que ne pouvait plus
contrôler sa base sas et de ses députés
c'était devenu taux particulièrement
duquenne qu'est ce que c'est que le
monsieur tremblay c'est une tentative à
nouveau de tricher à l'élection de deux
nuls pain en obtenant du président de
l'ukraine qu'il jette du discrédit sur
l'adversaire le plus importante dans la
tranche à cette élection
donc certains étaient trop il si je
pense qu'il ya un élément de principe ne
pense qu'on sera
sur une liste des alliés que le plus
d'endroits abusent de la construction
parce que c'est ça la destitution
on peut la supposition de destitution
pour abus de pouvoir ou abus de la
confiance publique et moi je trouve à
systématiquement abusé de sang froid
depuis son élection de pique nique
l'ukraine ces agissements ukraine sont
que la dernière version de ça mais on
pourrait parler de son pardon au shérif
arpaio arizona - paris et g de sucre en
apogée dit le directeur des pillages
pour moitié ce directeur refuse elle de
terminer une enquête sera un allié
politique ne se trompe pas la solution
il admet ce sont deux visions de nbc
ayant ya toute cette histoire de des
fonds pour la construction du mur dont
l'intro se présente après 35 jours de
fermeture du gouvernement américain il
se présente pour des bons finalement je
vais évoquer cette voiture gens ce qui
va permettre de rire vous à d'autres
fins les fonds qui ont été votées par le
congrès on part deux milliards de
dollars d'ici là le monde est d'allouer
des fonds alors je me retrouve voiture
genre mais en même temps il me dit il
dit a été dit mais vous savez je pense
que j'espère c'est maintenant je
pourrais attendre alors il n'y a pas de
france élite des violations de la
constitution comme le bras mais c'est de
la vieille histoire je m'excuse décès de
la vieille histoire parce qu'à chaque
jour il ya quelque chose de nouveau à
des derniers jours c'était l'histoire le
bras de fer avec dans l'histoire de deux
militaires qui ont reçu leur part dans
tout ça
bon le congédiement d'un haut
responsable militaire
justement parlant des militaires
capturés sens et son voyage il revient
en ce moment a dit à deux heures de
washington me dit on on le suit pape et
et puis voici les images où je vous
préviens à l'avancé les images de la
maison blanche alors c'est différent des
images des grands réseaux à la vidéo de
la visite de trempe en afghanistan des
images se succèdent très rapidement et
tous les murs et c'est là c'est une
pluie de militaires qu'il salue le
président ça va beaucoup plus rapidement
et c'est en accéléré
c'est un autre truc algérianité si oui
je le dis parce que les gens peuvent
aller voir le film d'origine maintenant
parlez moi de la conscience militaires
américains de ce2 du pouvoir militaire
américain qui reste pas silencieux mais
qui ont le sens gronder en arrière j'ai
jamais entendu ça moi je jamais vu ça de
ma vie moi des militaires américains
faire sentir que ça ne passe pas c'est
quelque chose que vous formez l'autorité
de la hiérarchie militaire n'est pas du
tout content que monsieur 30 se soit
immiscé dans la sanction
certains militaires de la ba qui ont été
accusés de crimes de guerre les
officiers supérieurs n'ont pas convaincu
je n'ai pas vu de tout ce qu'en pensent
les militaires de la part d'un truc mais
les soldats je n'ai pas vu le sondage
lancé par d'autres chantages que la
plupart des militaires sont d'allégeance
républicaine donc possiblement ils sont
favorables à un magistrat d'un autre
côté on a vu les militaires des tomates
qui se sont plaint beaucoup de la
décision de monsieur d'évacuer ou de
retirer de la syrie leurs effectifs
militaires chez les militants semblent
avoir vu sa prison dès qu on fait
probable papa donc je sais pas très bien
il faut faire attention de huit étages
c'est une très grande organisation il ya
plusieurs appareils et marines le mari
de dix millions de personnes en fait
donc ya plusieurs étages aussi en termes
de hiérarchie faut faire attention
de quoi mais c'est certain que si vous
êtes de tatiana merghani ce temps et que
le plus d'envié roi ben laden
l'action gas c'est très bien et
apparemment sur les images c'est une
vraie d'un transfèrement entre bush
avait fait il ya quelques années qu'il
ne reste plus une telle une des nos
plastique
est ce qu a pas de danger pour les
militaires américains d'être comme ça
utiliser et ensuite jeté comme monsieur
thual a fait avec beaucoup des gens qui
ont travaillé pour lui et qui les
soutenait vous avez raison vous avez
raison il ya un danger
ce qu'ils me doivent ce qui m'étonne
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
nantis et qui vont voir le site rêvé que
monsieur preuve malgré le danger parce
que vous avez raison monsieur trente
petites minutes des gens ils exigent
genevois y est c'est fait nous est notée
atteinte unique et un 15 juillet son
tour de monter danois si vous habitez
gens il n'a pas de rire t il de il mais
il ne rejette une réserve près c'est une
utilisation à attentionné qu'une avant
et il ya encore des gens qui apparemment
quoi qu'on dise pour un quart par des
journalistes qu' il ya parfois des
difficultés pour recruter déjà 28 ans
justement parce que on peut alors s est
présenté comme l explique d'où l'idée
pas d'action beaucoup plus intime avec
washington que je n'arrêtais pas de
penser que hier plusieurs pressions qui
ne sent pas professeur m'a rien merci
beaucoup nous avoir parlé d'un des états
américains où vont se jouer des
prochaines élections c'est sûr et
certain
et puis vous êtes dans un coin très
conservateur donc on aura l'occasion de
certainement de vous reparler de ce qui
se passe chez vous un moment donné on
voit c'était le professeur daniel m'a
rien de politique américaine à la sainte
flore dans le coin dolla d'orlando pas
loin de là en tout cas je dis pas loin
de là il habite pas loin de d'ornano
mais l'université et à orlando de
prescillia disney l'amdh ans mais là
aussi c'est vrai ah bon c'est vrai ces
raisons je vous promets oublier ça j'ai
la tête ailleurs
à la station spatiale
notre boule de couleur deuxième tour
combien une boule à perdre 30 parfait
combien de vies ont été perdues et par
qui au dernier g20 bull par mois parfait
jeudi parfait parce que c'est pas
c'est je vous réciter la magie alors
deuxième question la fiche quand même à
l'écran voici la fortune du candidat
démocrate à la présidence
non la fortune du nasdaq démocrate à la
présidence américaine michael bloomberg
et de combien de fois plus grosse que
celle de trump je sais que ma source
ces forums ça c'est très important de
citer ces papillons des banques non sur
cindy fois plus grosses la fortune de
michael bloomberg
est-ce que c'est trés soit plus grosse
est ce que ces dix sept fois plus grosse
ou est ce que c'est aucune de ces
réponses aux alors là j'ai avec le juste
milieu
ouais donc très fort c'est quoi une
mauvaise foi plus grosse c'est la juste
très cb c'est pas tout à fait au mieux
ça sera baissée moi je dirais milieu y'a
rien que le scientifique l'attend donc
tu fais comme ça au pif au pif pas mon
cas je vais retourner avec des parce que
je sais que michael bloomberg vient de
dépenser cette semaine 40 millions de
dollars pour des publicités pour sa
candidature alors c'est pour ça que je
me dis que lui il est vraiment à willy
dallay streit espère qu'ils n'ont pas
l'air alors tous les deux et au pif
ouais et raf vous avez tous les deux la
mauvaise réponse concernant ses 53
milliards de da selon m pour en savoir
plus sur ce qu'on entend discuter
aujourd'hui nous la politique
internationale ça nous touche à nos vies
c'est notre spécialité
alors on a été sur notre site web voir
ce qui a été plus récent produit par
notamment alice vers cannes est
certainement certains de vous étiez vous
lâché un cri d'un coup c'est à toronto a
tilté à des pressions de donald trump
sur l'ex-président ukrainien une
histoire que personne ne discute à
washington personne à part nous on en
parle
trump qui accorde un pardon présidentiel
un vieil ami ex militaires canadiennes
clara connu d'autres histoires à
scandale de les voir cedex premier
ministre canadien qui se prononce qu'est
ce qu'ils pensent les tranches
j'entretiens autoroutes ça aurait été
intéressant d'entendre jean chrétien
répondent à donald trump malheureusement
ça se fera pas ils m'ont dit que ça
reste intéressant
il ya comme 15 1 2 qui les sépare et
puis escarmouches x qui conseille aux
caennais ou aux dirigeants canadiens de
faire comme angers hériteront comment on
peut gérer l'emploi du temps parce que
ça c'est qu'elle fait c'est fait assez
rapidement
17 jours nous dit joue pas depuis n'est
plus qu'il ya dix jours ses marques et
le canada à l'onu
ouais geste de bravoure mais apparemment
ce club il boit il y a autre chose à
cette soir c'est à dire voilà séduit la
boule rôle toujours c'est une bonne
chose troisième jeu alors là on ira dire
combien de points 50 points je n'ai pas
un petit reste combien pain pour le
troisième jeu c'est un troisième et
dernier jeu ça déboule vite cette
semaine à monter un mensonge
ouais laquelle de ces affirmations sujet
d'une trempette au mensonge je pense que
c'est bien de dire être homme n'a jamais
fait faillite
est-ce que c'est à trump n'a jamais fait
faillite j'ai oublié l'ailette mais on
comprend b trempe était un partisan du
parti démocrate
est ce que c'est c'est rome s'est marié
trois fois
ou est-ce que le mensonge trempe et
bachelier en sciences économiques
quel est le mensonge parmi les cas n'a
été partisan du parti démocrate sens
notre membre entre partisans et membres
il ya tout un fossé non partisan c'est
quelqu'un qui cliquent âme qui aiment
les idées d'un parti qui aiment les
idées du parti démocrate ouais je sais
qu'il a été proche de celle arrivée bon
mains du maire croire le foot
ouais il n'a jamais fait faillite
peut-être peut-être fait d'accord alors
j'ai tenté de me taire accord décidé on
va coûter parisse maintenant bah moi
j'hésite entre trump s'est marié trois
fois parce que je me suis dit wenger
et dès maintenant son épouse donc ou en
fermant des dasri en sciences
économiques ont aussi plongé c'est
qu'elle manie que lundi pour une
université est un des blancs en gestion
la réponse quelle est votre réponse
maryse il s'est marié trois fois
bon les deux sont les deux informations
sont vraies il s'est marié trois fois il
n'a jamais failli et ce sont ces
compagnies à six reprises qui ont fait
faillite
d'accord mais qui est pas un enseignant
s'est inscrite bachelier en sciences
humaines partisans du parti démocrate
la vie dans les années 80 aussi qu'il
n'a jamais fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je vous accorde toujours un peu joué
alors vous conservez tous vos points
puisque la question était une fausse
question c'est un jeu à 9 me sur la
fausse question alors on cesse de planer
on veut bien sûr tu as quoi c'est
toujours le vendredi c'est l'occasion
d'avoir du plaisir ensemble et les jeux
de la semaine c'est quoi c'est moi c'est
l'image c'est ce qui s'est passé pendant
vos questions et vous devez déterminer
quelle est l'image cette semaine l'image
est belle journée moi pas quelque chose
qui s'est passé au canada
non pas vraiment je dirais non pas
vraiment non on va passer aux câlins
bayard il ya eu des choses qui sont
autoritaires il ya eu des répercussions
ou des conséquences au canada mais ça ne
s'est pas passé au canada
c'est est-ce que ça s'est passé aux
états unis ça s'est passé aux états unis
bien sûr ça c'est tout ce passe aux
etats-unis depuis un bout de temps
qu'est-ce que si est-ce que sa mauvaise
c'est ce que ça sèche l'environnement
non ça touche pas d'optique bah oui ça
touche la politique c'est la politique à
ce que sa tâche est parti en particulier
bah oui ça touche quelque fois quelque
chose comme ça à partie un particulier
ou et peut-être quelqu'un dans un autre
personnage c'est un délit oui c'était un
déguisement déguisement il a voulu par
éliminer notre vieux mila imiter un
certain schwarzenegger bon on va
regarder les images de semaine c'est pas
chouette ce n'est guère annonce n'a pas
chaussé les langes pensée terroir qui
aboutit donc à la fois encore notre dos
na waie les bohainois donald encore
encore fait mieux mais c'est la réalité
une des réalités parce que je vous ai
caché les autres images je pas osé vous
présenter parce que celle de droite a
pointé est trafiquée noms célèbres sam
key lorsqu'on le voit en direct à la
télé d'ailleurs c'est bien habillés
selon plein des gens je trouve c'est
quand même assez grave de rire des du
poids des gens mais dans ce cas ci je
pense qu'il l'a un peu comme me chercher
voici sa compétition ça c'est que c'est
assez beau et puis c'est le plus gros
ghana c'est sans commentaire
les images parlent d'elles mêmes le
grand gagnant c'est lui a dit qu'il
avait fait un match de boxe il ya
quelques années il a six ou sept ans il
a pris un peu de poids relatif des
conservateurs les derniers matches où
est ben oui les mêmes tout récemment
mais
c'est une fausse image c'est le ter
aujourd'hui fausse question fausse image
mais concerne le premier ministre du
canada
j'ose croire que c'est vrai parce qu'on
l'a vu pendant la dernière élection
peut-être un ou deux kilos là il faut
rassurer les gens qui nous regardent
oui on nous écoute on ne fera pas ce
genre de photomontages nouman nous on a
dit qu'il en va en réalité on indique
l'oms sur la télévision canadienne c'est
dix de moins nous on est l intelligent
internationale c'est superbe c'est mieux
comme ça
voilà un kilo c'est quoi c'est combien
le lycée et argon 6,6 livre iii
compliqué cette affaire doit ses 450
grammes c'est comme à laval je ne sais
trop bien ville à des kilomètres et des
mines ces deux points de livres 1 kg
d'accord c'est le même temps on nous a
soufflé à l'oreille alors la semaine
prochaine une émission spéciale sur les
37 ans du système métrique au canada
notamment parce que je serais pas là
[Rires]
gentil
[Musique]